avec deux enfants tout est devenu plus
compliqué
j'ai tout je cherche une nounou alors
moi je m'appelle luis tu excusez moi
mais je crois que quelqu'un est en train
de se réveiller au vous avez lui fini
[Musique]
non
myriam vous pouvez partir tranquille
vous méfier
à votre formidable famille ça les super
fatigué on voit quand même vos enfants
wyss
[Musique]
plus en plus tôt oui oui je leur très
peu
oui
la ville a jamais comme ça c'est compris
duré que quelques secondes
tu étais un homme pourrait le faire
battant mènera cadre approuvé tout seul
et dur a beau crier et pleurer personne
interpellée
je m'inquiète pour milad je passe plus
de temps avec quelqu'un qui est temps
qu'on s'en sépare
beloved m'occuper de 40 d'autre part des
enfants 1
et tu vas faire comment quand ils seront
plus là
ils sont aujourd'hui
[Musique]
mise en confiance pictave